press conference 2011 will start this year
under the title the issue
hero
visit the hero gustav mahler big
questions about
man art and god
we do it here in dutch opera
and we do it very much to my delight in
collaboration with an orchestra what
terribly important
was a concert for anal's career
when he seemed to be composing
he got no recognition he was
literally and figuratively vomited by
the music hey let he was misunderstood
with the exception here in amsterdam it
wants mengelberg the great conductor and what
does Hemelberg do when he  25 years
chief conductor of the concert hall
orchestra he organizes a party in 1920 channels
this book belonged to you this way will
unite us the grinding feast
the music is no longer a distraction
stimulant or even reprehensible
delusion take
music is surrender to the mind music
knows no  stans or borders
music is the symbol none the higher
get hurt
male was a comp  onist who ask very big
questions
such as why suffering does death exist god
why is there death
what can art what is allowed art what
makes life worth living be
happy important in life
love can you important place
humor health
friends very important attention to
each other
but ask those questions at the time of
a european culture you use a
crisis we see those crisis
phenomena back
it version's me what then
started to take root as a first
we now see again in the figure of
wilders and we see  back in france and
we see it again in hungary and the
chaos me further economic crisis
phenomena we see it again
i think questions asked many times are
extremely important for
our view because we have
n't asked those questions for too long too long
have done for decades his arms are
well with the economy when an uncle
is well with the banks when
the te is well  technology if it
goes well with the export and if it goes a little
less that we can
cut back enough and we keep ourselves
busy with all kinds of things and the newspapers
are full of it and the tool shows
are already writing a book about it
but  never get me the vine question
really are going to put the oil
what we wanted to do now on may 4,
2011 see if we can get it back just once
put him here and start
a conversation with him about the
big questions he asked in two
debates and and  masterclass
are we going to look at how day times
bad about how we think about what are
the differences was it still agreement
in the final debate we are going to talk about
the two great myth wrong dust box ivo wrong
that is the idea of striving for p
wer everything  to be able to have under control
have the absolute knowledge
parcival that is more the seeking spirit
to pause for a day on the basis of
valleys and his music and
then ask ourselves whose are we
where  we are working on what
is really important to us now
and let's hope that
interest will also come to you in the netherlands
we call that the dutch spring and
inspired by that genius those
genius compositions that and gustav mahler
gave us